right well welcome everyone to what is
the final cabinet of this council and
welcome Peter and can I just say that in
terms of the reallocation of the
accountabilities that jackie Harris has
that's now being done and published on
the website and as this is the final
count final cabinet of this council
it is rather unfortunate I think that we
will be saying farewell to a number of
members of cabinet so Mike brain he's
not standing so farewell Mike we will
miss you
Stephen Phil will is not standing so
farewell Stephen and we will miss you
and I understand that councillor Morse
is not standing so farewell I would say
we will miss you I am sure you will take
that in the spirit in which it is
intended I think I think I have to say
later you will actually be missed
because you have added value in your own
inimitable style over the period were
diving later and finally we say farewell
to Morris house and I think what I can
really say is that I will miss you all
so thank you for your contribution
however sometimes that thank he was in
the case of councillor Moses through
gritted teeth sorry Peter discount
resisting
but anyhow so moving on with the agenda
apologies for absence thank you
disclosures of interest minutes many to
agreed in that case can we move on to
development requirements supplementary
planning documents which I believe is
counselor pemberton Thank You leader
this is the latest tranche of
development requirements supplementary
planning documents covering access and
connectivity of the new development Part
C buildings and layouts Part D
residential amenity Part F self build
custom build and modular housing part J
general and local housing needs part s
and specialized housing part T following
on from the other ten that have already
been adopted leader it's a fairly simple
request that the recommendation to
cancel is that this but the Council
formally adopts Part C D F J and s and T
as part of the development requirements
supplementary planning documents any
questions or any questions any debate
I'll take that as a no so are we all
happy with this recommendation to
council in that case I do the next item
again we have councillor Pemberton Thank
You leader this is the really
Neighborhood Development Plan which has
reached the pre submission consultation
stage and under regulation 14 I just
want to first of all thanks to Matthew
Neal for his hard work here members of
cabinets this is the point at which
we're making our formal responses to the
to the NDP and again I'd also like to
pay some tributes to the work done by
the brewery NDP group the recommendation
is that the comments at Appendix 1 be
endorsed and submitted to the Parish
Council as the
more response to the pre-submission
consultation process associated with the
draught brewery neighborhood development
plan which is at appendix 2 minor
changes in a separate document those
cover grammar and other sort of
technical bits and pieces is there any
discussion or any questions on this
agenda item I'll take that as a no in
that case are we all happy with the
recommendation on page 15 thank you
moving on thank you very much leader the
Beaudesert enhan Leonarda Neighborhood
Development Plan has reached the same
points the regulation 14 stage where
this Authority submits comments to
support the Beaudesert and Henley Nardin
joint parish council NDP group again I'd
like to thank Matthew Neill for all of
his hard work in producing the schedule
of comments which will inform the next
stage of the NDP process and as with the
previous one the significant comments
are at appendix 2 there is a separate
document covering grammatical issues and
the recommendation is that though that
schedule of significant comments be
endorsed and submitted to Beaudesert and
Henley Nardin joint parish council as
this authority's formal response in the
pre consultation process I'll leave it
at that for the moment I'm sure Thank
You chairman I echo strongly the words
that councillor Pemberton on this and I
also will give my thanks to Matthew Neal
and his team as you probably have done
in guiding this parish council through
this particular document the comments
that have been made I think will help to
build further on the basis of what is
already a very good plan therefore
I support Thank You counselor will with
that are there any other questions or
any more debate from this agenda item I
will take that as a no so cabinets
are you happy with the recommendation on
page 29
great thank you cabinets we now move on
to the on bloc items statements and no
request has been made to the leader at
the start of the meeting from item to be
discussed so we go through seven
strategic policy advisory group eight
affordable housing delivery working
group and struck fir'd upon Aven markets
forum and to receive and note those
minutes our cabinet happy with that and
you will notice that the minutes of this
strategic policy advisory group have
been updated noted thank you everyone
there has been no urgent business so
with that and once again with my thanks
to the members of cabinet who are
standing down this year and the
councillor Moss as leader of the
Opposition thank you meeting closed
thank you